and everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm and today we're going
to be looking at the Albin counter game
bit which is a defense against the
Queens gambit line so we'll go ahead and
get into it first move upon before Mike
responds pawn to e5 white pawn c4 vise
going to respond pawn e5 and this is the
elven counter gambit right here and
right away any player that plays the
Queen's game at line for white is going
to be at a book in there a lot of times
going to be either comfort mode a lot of
players that play the Queen's game that
are not too familiar with the Alvin
counter game it so it is debatable
whether this is a fundamentally sound
defense if white plays correctly he can
maintain his advantage throughout the
game as white can do many times in the
opening but I feel if they're not well
versed in defending the Alpen counter
game black has a lot of good counter
play it's a very aggressive style so if
you you like playing aggressive and you
like playing aggressive as black this is
very good and white has a lot of
opportunities to mess up and so we're
going to go over what that looks like
today we're going to go over the main
line the main line is simply just pawn
taking on e5 we're going to go ahead and
take a look at some of the other moves
that you may see if white is not too
versed in this defense we'll take a look
at that see what both sides should do if
that happens then we'll go and take a
look at the main line which you'll see
more often than not and how both sides
should play accordingly so one of the
first thing you'll see you may see the C
pawn here capture on d5 obviously it's
not recommended but you may see it and
that's simply going to look like pawn
captures on d5 and black from here can
just take on d5 with his queen now from
here you may see a couple things from
white obviously he would want to get
this Queen out of here a lot of times
you'll see players develop their knights
thinking that they can force this Queen
back basically gaining a tempo and
development so you may see
the night come to see three but from
here black can actually just continue
and take on d4 and if white now besides
to capture the Queen then black in
recapture and now white is forced to
move his piece more than once in opening
you never want to move your minor pieces
more than once an opening if you don't
have to and so we are capturing at the
same time forcing white to move his
minor piece on c3 not really recommended
for why blacks going to have a very good
game here another thing you may see is
you may simply instead of Knight to c3
you may see pawn to e3 putting another
defender on this d4 pawn from here
though black can simply capture with his
deep on and then either way if white
decides to recapture or he decides to
recapture with his Queen and we trade
off Queens either way he's going to have
this isolated pawn on the D file and
when it comes to the endgame you never
really want to have an isolated pawn
it's just very hard to defend and if
your opponent is good and well versed in
the endgame it's going to be very easy
for him to manipulate and win with an
isolated pawn if it's even in material
so that's definitely not recommended for
white another move you may see you may
just see Knight to f3 from here white
excuse me black can simply just take on
d4 obviously if light decides to take
then we're even in material if he
decides to take with his his Queen here
we can just recapture blacks going to
have a fine game here as you can see in
all these we're pretty much breaking up
any mainline book line that white may be
familiar with playing the Queen's Gambit
line and that's why I kind of like the
Allan counter game it most players that
play the Queens gambit are just going to
be so out of their element that even if
it just reaches equality I feel like
that's good for black because so many
people are so studied up as white that
they're not going to know how to
approach this correctly so you may not
see the the first move capture with a C
pawn
another thing you may see from here you
may see simply why develop his Knight to
c3 very common move in the Queen's
Gambit line from here but I can simply
capture the C pawn on c4 and then White
has a decision to make if he wants to
capture our a pawn then we can simply
come in take his queen he's obviously
going to probably choose with his Knight
to capture and then from here we can
simply develop our our Knight to c6
attacking this epon on e5 likes going to
have a very good game here another thing
you may see you may see immediately
white moves pawn to e3 from here well I
can simply take on d4 and then if white
responds and recaptures with his pawn
then we can simply just develop our
Knight to f6 and we're going to have a
completely fine game here another thing
you may see probably not the most
recommended so if you do see it just
know that it's not a very good move by
white you may see his develop his Knight
to f3 basically attacking our pawn on e5
but we're simply just going to push that
forward attacking the knight again
making the minor piece move more than
once which you never want to do if you
don't have to from here the knight
really doesn't have a lot of good
squares he can obviously move to g5 or
ePHI then we can simply move our F pawn
a little farther and force him back
again if he moves his Knight - D - it's
really hindering the development of his
other night in the alb encounter game it
the knight on b1 would actually really
like to come to d2 so this is kind of
blocking his natural development from
here we can simply develop our Knight to
f6 and we're going to have a fine game
here as you can see we're attacking all
these light squares and we're defending
our pawns on the D for the d5 and the e4
squares we're going to have a very fine
game here what you will see though
excuse me we'll come back here is the
main line you're going to see this more
often than not and that's simply pawn
capturing on e5 and then from here we're
going to move our pawn forward to d4 and
this is where we really get into the
heart of the Albin counter gambit now
White has a lot of different options and
one of which is going to be the Lasker
trap that black can bring about and if
you haven't seen the Alaska trap video
that it you can check that out I'm going
to do a quick recap of it basically
looks like this why it's going to bring
his pawn to e3 he this pawn on d4 is a
very big strength for black it's a huge
weakness for white so he's gonna try to
do anything he can to get rid of this
obviously he can't develop his Knight to
c3 which he'd like to he can't take yet
with his Queen because our Queens here
so a lot of times you may just see pawn
to e3 from here we're simply going to
disregard that we're going to bring our
Bishop to b4 if he blocks with his
Bishop on d2 attacking our Bishop we're
simply going to avoid this take on e3
after he takes our piece on b4 thinking
maybe we just left a piece hanging then
we're simply going to continue check the
king when the King moves we're going to
recapture excuse me capture on do you
want and under promote to a knight
checking the King here and blacks going
to have a tremendous game and white can
easily lose this game pretty easy so if
you want the full variations of all the
Lasker trap you can check out the other
video we're going to go ahead and look
at some other variations obviously you
won't see the e3 move all the time the
main line is going to be and this is
what I recommend for y2 obviously a lot
of people always ask me what should y do
what's the correct play white Roma just
develop his knight to f3 he's attacking
putting more pressure on this d4 pawn
and he's putting his knight on a very
good square and he's not putting himself
in jeopardy of falling in any traps from
here
black is simply going to develop his
knight to c6 and then a lot of times in
the alb encounter game it you're just
going to see white Finch head was Bishop
to the Kings side basically putting a
lot of pressure on this diagonal that h1
to a diagonal black really wants to
develop his bishop he wants to develop
his queen probably do like d7 and then
he wants to Castle queenside he really
wants to I down on this D file this d4
pawn is very strong so he really wants
to put his Queen here on d7 and then
Castle queenside put his rookie Iran d8
and just I down on this D file so that's
something to keep in mind when you are
playing Albin counter game it so from
here you may see white just phantoms
Bishop to the King side on g2 from here
play as follows you're going to develop
our Bishop to e6 you may see one they
may be in shadow already more than
likely though you'll see them develop
their night to d2 obviously we are
attacking this pawn on c4 so you may see
him just develop their night to d2 since
we are attacking they want to put a
defender on there from here we're simply
just going to bring our Queen to d7
remember we just want to keep putting
pressure on this file then from here you
may see a male develop their Bishop to
g2 we're simply going to castle putting
a lot of pressure on the D file from
here you'll probably see white castle
and from here we're just going to bring
our our knight to e7 and from here
Knight can come two places one he can
come to g6 attacking the pawn on e5 we
have both our tonight's attack event or
you may see him bring our Knight to f5
putting another defender on our d4 pawn
so there's a lot of different options
for black obviously we are down to
material one pawn but we have a very
good pawn on d4 and we have a lot of
good attacking ideas obviously he's
Castle kingside we're Castle queenside
so more than likely we may want to push
our pawns up on the King side but he as
well may push his pawns up on the Queen
side so just keep out for that
it's basically going to be a very
aggressive game by both sides since it
is canceled on different sides but these
are some of the common ideas you want to
look for as white and as black as you
play through this so hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you haven't
already please subscribe and thanks for
watching and look out for more videos in
the future